Carrie Bradshaw said it best when she
said beauty is fleeting
but a rent-controlled apartment
overlooking the park is forever but
where can Americans afford to live on
their own we developed the Carrie
Bradshaw index to measure the
affordability of the humble studio
apartments in 100 of America's largest
cities the result was bad news for
aspiring carries in 62 out of 100 cities
a studio apartment is well beyond the
means of the average worker
unsurprisingly New York is the most
unaffordable on average tenants should
probably earn at least one hundred and
forty thousand dollars to afford a room
of their own in Miami the median salary
of forty four thousand dollars is well
below the required 89 000 but for a
flexible renter some affordable options
remain in cities like St Louis
Cincinnati Detroit and Minneapolis the
average worker earns more than what is
needed to comfortably rent a studio
relocate wisely and you might be able to
afford the luxury of a separate living
room or even Carrie's walk-in wardrobe